Das ist das Podcast im Fonds, das ist das Podcast im Fonds, das ist das Podcast im Fonds, der man das nicht vornehmen, das ist das Podcast im Fonds, die mit Städten und Flü die Welt. Das ist das Podcast-Effekt, der Podcast-Effekt vor den Armen. Das ist das Podcast-Effekt, mit Stimme, die Zählung für die Welt. Das ist das Podcast-Effekt, herzlich willkommen zu dieser neuen Folge, das Podcast UFO in, Podcast UFO, hi, endlich mal wieder die alte Besetzung, endlich mal wieder Oldschool, the boys are back in town, möchte ich sagen. Möchtest du sagen, mach lieber nicht, aber es ist richtig, wir sind beide am Start und freuen uns sehr, gemeinsam mal wieder in dieser guten alten Besetzung diese Folge zu bestreiten. Hallo Stefan! Hallo Florentin, da hinten, hi! Und hallo an unseren dritten Kompagnon hier heute, Tim, der für uns dieses Intro geschrieben und performt hat. Geschrieben, komponiert und arrangiert hat. Ja, alles zusammen hat er. Ein Arrangeur, Kompositeur und. Das ist das Beste, was man sein kann. Was machst du so beruflich? Ich bin ein Arrangeur. Arrangeur. Je suis Arrangeur. Je suis Arrangeur. Das ist das Wichtigste beim Französisch lernen, dass immer nachdem jemand einen Satz gesagt hat, man erst mal so ein, je suis un Oranger. Ja, wie ich mal betitelt wurde, weil es mich schlecht übersetzt war, am Anfang so ein Konzept von einer Serie und da wurde ich als Author, The Author, Stefan, betitelt und irgendwie war es einfach falsch, weil jemand nicht Writer geschrieben hat, aber es klang fast grösser. Ja klang so wie dieses Französische Auteur. Ja, absolut. Wahnsinnig gross und mächtig und dann habe ich gesagt, komm, lass stehen. Ja, im Englischen wird es ja klar getrennt, von den Vollidioten die Writer und den Künstlern die Authors. Das heißt, du könntest sagen, I'm a writer, but I want to be an author. I'm a writer, but I want to be an author. I'm just a guter olden West Virginia. Gut, old South Carolina. Wenn die Stars ein Widerer sind, dann werde ich ein Widerer mit diesen hohen Balleten. Aber ich bin kein Widerer. Ich bin kein Widerer. Immer Gitarren im Hintergrund. Denkt euch das, aber Veranda sitzend. Wäre das was für dich eigentlich?
Ich sage mal mit dem Geld, was wir hier mit dem Podcast verdienen, könntest du jetzt schon so eine schäbige Drecksbude dir irgendwo in West Virginia kaufen? Mit einer riesigen Veranda. Kleines Haus, grosse Veranda. Kleines Haus, grosses Haus, kleine Veranda vielleicht auch. Ich weiß nicht, wo dein Schwerpunkt liegt. Aber mit so einem knzigen Holzschaukelstuhl, einer Gitarre und einer Enkeltochter auf dem Schoß. Wäre das was für dich, tendenziell eine Zukunftsperspektive? Ja, finde ich gut. Ich mag diese Schaukelstühe total gern, natürlich so mit einer Schrotflinte auf dem Schoß und dann einfach schön in den Sonnenuntergang hineinstarren. Schießen. Einfach schön, geh unter jetzt! Angry Man shoots its son Sun. Angry Man Shoots in Sun, wäre das was für dich, so ein Hit, wo man nicht sehen könnte, irgendwie so ein Viral-Hit 2009 vielleicht? Ja, auf jeden Fall. Das ist einerseits, ich versuche den Klimawandel zu lösen, habe aber trotzdem so diese Redneck-Attitüde, das heißt, es kommt so ein bisschen zusammen. Das finde ich eigentlich ganz schön, aber das finde ich total toll, diese Veranda, so dieses erhöhte Podest. Bühne, letztlich eine Bühne. Ist es nicht so, weil amerikanische Häuser keinen Keller haben, deswegen fängt der erste Stock, ist das Erdgeschoss erhöht, damit man einen Keller hat? Ich weiß nicht, ob da überhaupt irgendwas ist. Ich habe keine Ahnung, ich weiß es nicht genau. Ja, ich bin mir nicht sicher. Ich finde es nur, also das schwingt total viel mit direkt. Man weiss auch immer, wie es klingt. Weil diese Grillen, die so laut Ohren betäubend zirpen, ganz toll auch, dass er nachts rausgeht und es einfach so ein kontinuierliches Ja, ja. Und jeder schreit Ruhe, Ruhe, Ruhe, Ruhe, psch, psch. Halt mir jetzt die Klappe. Nein, du hast die Klappe. Können wir alle kurz auf drei, Leute! Nein, du hast die Klappe. Und dann schlagartig wie bei TV Total das Publikum. Ganz, ganz ruhig. Ja. Das wäre gruselig, oder, wenn so alle Tiere plötzlich aufhören und sich alle so zusammenreißen, weil alle sagen, wir machen das meiste über Geruchsstoffe. Wir müssen eigentlich gar nicht reden. Zack. Alle Tiere von jetzt auf gleich ruhig und gucken auf die Uhr und es ist genau so zwölf Uhr oder sowas. Ja. Das wäre gruselig. Nachtruhe. Herrscht Nachtruhe jetzt. Das wäre toll, wenn alle Tiere von einem Tag auf den anderen weg sind und man es fragt und man merkt es erst gar nicht. Und wo sind die? Und alle freuen sich, sind wir erst mal glücklich. Wieso glücklich?
Naja, weil du nicht dieses nervige Vogelgezwitschen hast, wenn du die Hingerödel und dann irgendwann merkt man, oh, das hat aber doch Konsequenzen. Ein sehr langweiliger Film, vornachmittag einfach mal so ein bisschen dahin plätschern, auch mal ganz nett, auch mal ganz nett, einfach so für nebenbei, finde ich ganz gut. Bist du jemand, der Notizen macht? Ja, doch, ich, ich meine regelmäßig Notizen, auch wenn ich zum Beispiel, oh, ich wollte gerade sagen, ein Gespräch überhöre. Falsch. Stalker. Entschuldigung. Stalker. Nee, ich glaube, das habe ich mittlerweile häufig gehört, dass Leute in unserem Alter Überhören sagen. Das ist im Deutschen ganz falsch benutzt. Das ist aus dem Englischen übernommen, to overhear something, aber Überhören heißt, das habe ich wohl überhört, im Sinne von habe ich nicht gehört. Also Überhören ist eigentlich komplett falsch benutzt, die englische Sprache greift also gerade massiv in unsere deutsche Sprache ein. Was wäre dann das richtige Wort für eine Konversation, lauschen, die man nicht… Belauschen oder mitbekommen. Naja, aber… Kommt drauf an, also wenn ich jetzt meine… Ich will ja schon so ein bisschen diese voyeuristische Note mit drin haben. Belauschen. Belauschen? Aber belauschen mich zu aggressiv war schon. Was ich meine ist, wenn ich ein Gespräch in der Bahn mitbekomme, dann mache ich mir durchaus Notizen, wenn mir der Dialog gefällt. Ich würde aber sagen, das sind zwei verschiedene Worte, weil belauschen bedeutet, ich möchte aktiv zuhören, wohingegen überhören ist ein Gespräch in meiner Hörreichweite, das ich nicht ausblende. Nee, das ist auch to overhear. Ich muss mich nicht anstrengen, um hier zu hören, ich muss nicht aktiv das Ohr an die Tür pressen, wie ich bei lauschen nicht zuhören. Aber ich wehre mich auch nicht. Ich wehre mich nicht, normalerweise ist es der Anstand gebietet, dass man fremden Gesprächen zuhört. Ich bin nicht umhin gekommen, mitzuhören, das wär's doch. Aber to overhear ist falsch, überhören heißt nicht hören. Und du schreibst dann mit und da kriegst du deine genialen Dialogideen. Und dann irgendwann schaut man die dritte Staffel How to Sell Drugs und denkt sich, Moment mal, das ist genau das, was ich letztens zu Bianca gesagt habe. Wort für Wort! Ja, genau. Dietzer! Und dann so, Bianca, komm mal schnell, du hast doch behauptet, ich hätte das anders gesagt. Hier, hör dir das doch mal an, das ist doch unser Dialog aus dem Zug. Wir müssen unseren Umsatz steigern. Ja, aber wie sollen wir die holländischen Zusteller zufrieden kriegen? Das ist exakt das, was ich gesagt habe. Ja, na gut. Diebstahl. Ich bin ganz offen, Staffel zwei macht grösstenteils keinen Sinn, aber auch liegt einfach daran, weil ich dann im Zug hoffentlich die richtigen Dialogen mitbekommen habe. Creative Commons, muss man dann Leute fragen, so, Entschuldigung, ich habe gerade ihren sehr emotionalen Streit überhört. Nicht überhört! Äh, äh, äh, soll ich, komm nochmal. Entschuldigung, ich habe ganz kurz ihren sehr emotionalen Streit belauscht gerade. Ja, was? Können Sie mir die Rechte daran übertragen? Was? Ich gebe Ihnen 20 Euro. 20 Euro? 20 Euro und ich habe die Rechte an dem Dialog und dann gucken wir mal, was sie tun. Habe ich denn Recht? Na gut, das ist natürlich Interpretationssache. Also wir werden natürlich... Aber haben Sie das Gefühl, dass ich Recht habe, weil sie ist auch aufmerksam durchgeknallt. Naja, wir werden natürlich kameratechnisch da einige Sachen machen, um sie jetzt nicht... Werde ich gewinnen? Wer weiß, schauen Sie einen Film an. Wer spielt mich? Schauen Sie einen Film an. Wer spielt mich? Robbie De Niro. Robbie De Niro? Ja. Warum? Naja, also sie sind ja jetzt auch schon ein bisschen in die, also nicht, dass sie, nein, aber. Ich bin 38. Ja, aber sie haben so eine gewisse alte Seele in sich, die ich spüre durch ihre Augen. Gegen Vorschlag. Ich finde das fast ganz gut. Ryan Gosling spielt mich. Ryan Gosling, wir machen 10 Euro. Timothy Chalamet, ich gebe ihm 50 Euro. Okay, so machen wir es. Hollywood! Hollywood! It's the best word! Aber man hat keine Rechte an dem, was man sagt, oder? Man hat doch durchaus, je nachdem wie es gemeint ist. Wenn du vorher sagst, was jetzt kommt, ist gemeint, ist poetisch gemeint, dann musst du kurz die Poesie in den Poesiezwinkel machen und dann ist ab dann alles, was du sagst, nicht mehr Creative Commons. Okay. Aber hat er jetzt, jemand hat ja alle Melodien, Melodeien der Welt, die jetzt noch über waren, also quasi ohne Rhythmus. Aber alle Melodieabfolgen, naja, Melodieabfolgen sind ja begrenzt, weil du hast ja nur ein paar Töne auf der Klaviatur. Heißt, Melodieabfolgen sind begrenzt. Es hat jemand auf alle Melodien Urheberrecht angemeldet und das dann aber freigegeben für Creative Commons. Das war jetzt ja eine Idee von jemandem, der hat ein Programm geschrieben, das alle Melodien generiert hat, die es noch gibt. Und hat die jetzt der Öffentlichkeit freigegeben. Aber ohne Rhythmus, oder was? Ohne Rhythmus. Ja, weil unter der Prämisse, dass Rhythmus erstmal egal ist. Weil es gibt ja auch schon Präzedenzfälle, wo der Rhythmus keine Rolle gespielt hat. Und Leute verurteilt wurden. Wo spielt den Rhythmus keine Rolle? Das ist ja schon, wenn du sagst, oh the single ladies, oh the single ladies, das ist ja 80 Prozent Rhythmus. Bei diesem Song, bei diesem brillanten Song jetzt ja, Arrangement, aber nicht bei allen Sachen. Es gibt ja schon, es ist ja so ein bisschen so ein Satirstück. Ah, okay. Sorry, ich wusste nicht, dass wir in der Welt der Satire sind. Manchmal übersehe ich das. Naja, es ist ja schon eine echte Aktion, aber es zeigt natürlich auch, wo die Probleme sind. Weil es gibt schon Präzedenzfälle, wo halt wirklich einfach tatsächlich Melodien als geklaut verurteilt wurden. Ja, von Katy Perry gab es so einen gross Fall, mit ihrem Dark Horse. Genau, Dark Horse zum Beispiel. Wo sie tatsächlich gewonnen hat, glaube ich, was sehr merkwürdig ist. Naja, weil sie sehr viel Geld hat. Ach, stimmt. Oh nö, jetzt muss dieser Tizizynismus jetzt auch noch reinkommen. Katy Perry hat wahnsinnig viel Geld, mehr will ich nicht sagen. Mehr will ich nicht sagen. Unser guter Freund Adam Neely hat dazu auch gute Videos gemacht.
Adam Neely ist einer der besten The Lick. Ich habe gerade auch ein Shirt von ihm.
Echt? Du hast das Lick-Shirt?
Ich habe das The Lick-Shirt.
Wow.
Ja, es ist eine wohlbekannte Jazzfigur, die man ab und zu mal spielt, mit Augensfingern.
Adam Neely ist ein Bassassist kommt aus New York,
fantastischer, fantastischer Musiker,
studiert auch da an einer sehr bekannten Conservatory
Musik,
stellt auch mittlerweile schon fertig, weiß ich nicht genau,
fantastischer Bassist und der hat auch schon
über, auch übrigens über diesen Typen, der
alle Lieder, alle Melodien der Welt
angemeldet hat jetzt, hat er auch ein Video gemacht.
Perfekt. Unbedingt zu empfehlen. Und der hat neulich auch bei dem New York 24-Stunden-Marathon mitgemacht, wo, das war noch vor Corona, wo das noch möglich war, wo drei Musicals innerhalb von 24 Stunden geschrieben wurden. Wahnsinn, ne? Und am Ende waren super bekannte Komponisten auch dabei, die das Ganze beaufsichtigt haben und diese drei Teams geleitet haben. Und er war halt, glaube ich, im Transkribiert oder war im Arrangement-Team von einem dieser Komponisten und hat dann am Ende nochmal eine Lieder drüber geguckt und so. Und am Ende, nach 24 Stunden wurden Musicals, wirklich 90 Minuten Musicals aufgeführt in New York. Das ist schon echt krass. Die schaffen drei Musicals in 24 Stunden. Wir sitzen seit vier Jahren an unserem Musical und wir haben, hm, hm, hm, das ist der Anfang. Aber mehr haben wir noch nicht. Aber mega Anfang, aber mega Anfang. Ja, es ist ein guter Anfang, das sagen wir seit vier Jahren, aber es geht halt nicht weiter. Ich sage die ganze Zeit, wir müssen aber diesen Andrew Lloyd Webber Anfang hinkriegen, wo man sich alle Dinge vorstellen.
Also ich weiß nicht, wenn wir jetzt über Laptops sprechen, wenn das ein Laptop-Musical ist. Schwer in Kostüme zu bringen, aber ja. Ja, sagst du immer, das ist immer dein eines Argument. Ja, ja, ich denke halt immer direkt ans Kostüm, so ein Laptop ist super flach. Ja genau, ich sage nur, aber ich sage nur, wenn es ein Musicals wäre, würden. Ich sage halt, wenn wir es zu Smartphone machen, das kannst du halt viel einfacher in Kostümen. Wie dem auch sei. Dann würde ich trotzdem erstmal der erste Song so irgendwie sein, ich bin ein Samsung, hört mir zu, ich klingel so, so, so, so. Und dann kommt aber das iPhone und dann kommt diese Marimba-Melodie, die man kennt vom iPhone. Keine schlechte Idee auf jeden Fall. Jetzt gerade fliegt die ISS über uns, genau jetzt gerade. Ich habe mir einen Alert eingestellt, dass man, wenn die ISS über einen fliegt, man Google Alerts...
Ist das so alle halbe Stunde, oder?
Es ist so lächerlich häufig. Ich dachte erst, es wäre lustiger Spaß.
Ist das nicht eine App, die dir alle halbe Stunde eine Nachricht schickt?
Es ist viel zu häufig.
Aber hast du da so eine mentale Verbindung zur ISS, dass du einmal so kurz die Faust in die Luft reckst und sagst, yes, ihr schafft das.
Weg, weg mit dir.
Hau ab, du Metallungetüm vom Hilf.
Ah ja, er ist schon wieder weg.
Warum macht das eigentlich, aber ist es nicht, also jetzt mal Formel 1, da gilt ja die Regel, schneller desto lauter.
Besser.
Je schneller ein Auto fährt, njao.
Was war jetzt, wie schnell war das?
Das war 320, ich kann mal.
Und jetzt Achtung.
Ähnlich schnell.
Ähnlich schnell, ja.
Aber deswegen müsste nicht eigentlich die ISS, die ja wahnsinnig schnell ist, müsste diese
Und dann nach einer halben Stunde
Da kommt sie wieder.
Dann ist wieder so ein leises, am Horizont so ein leises eine halbe Stunde. Die NASA hätte sofort kein Geld mehr. Einfach so, Leute, die NASA... Wir entziehen euch alles. Macht's, oder wir geben ihr sehr viel Geld, damit sie es leiser machen. Kann auch eine Erpressung sein. Kann dieser Gärz nicht mal die Klappe halten! Hallo!
Oh, lau!
Das finde ich fantastisch, weil so könnte die NASA uns ja alle erpressen.
Wenn es uns nicht sofort mehr Geld gibt für Space Exploration and Exploitation, dann wird die noch lauter. Space Abuse.
Dann ist die noch lauter, dann machen wir die ISS noch viel lauter.
Nicht wie der Macarena den ganzen Tag.
Macarena, Ruhe! Aber ich habe extra den Radius ganz, ganz klein gestellt, damit ich nicht andauernd tausende Nachrichten bekomme, weil die rast ja um die Erde und deswegen habe ich den Radius um mich herum, 20 Meter um mich herum gestellt. Und nur wenn die genau über mir ist, in diesem 20-Meter-Radius, über der Erde, kriege ich diesen Alert.
Und der kommt trotzdem Das ändert das denn doch trotzdem einmal pro Tag. Einmal pro halbe Stunde. Wenn ich den Radius das häufiger eingestellt hätte, dann ist sie häufiger, würde die häufiger diesen Radius. Also es wabbelt so oder was? Ja, die Erde dreht sich ja auch und das Ding dreht sich und dann dreht sich alles und so. Rebel! Jedenfalls ist sie dann häufiger in diesem Radius, natürlich, wenn der Radius grösser ist. Checkt sie nicht, ne? Guckt sie mich an mit deinem kleinen Äuglein. Wenn die einmal alle halbe Stunde über uns ist. Nein, so ist sie. Warum ist es dann richtig, wie groß der Radius ist, der Matchradius? Ist sie ja nicht. Die fliegt ja so um die Erde, die Erde dreht sich. So, da kannst du ja ausdenken, wenn dann da ein grosser ... Hätte Stefan doch nur drei Hände, dann würde ich das jetzt verstehen, aber nein. Ja, warte, ich muss das Mikrofon kurz so hinlegen, so. Also die Erde dreht sich, ne, und die ISS fliegt um die Erde. Ja. So, und die trifft jeden Punkt mal, natürlich, weil die so rumfliegt.
Aber wenn dein Radius grösser ist und manchmal ... Also die Umlaufbahn ist nicht fix auf der Erde sozusagen, sondern die ... Gar nicht fix. Ach so. Gar nicht fix. Das heißt, wie oft hast du dann effektiv deine Alarmen? Drei Mal am Tag. Wow. Vier Mal am Tag. Kommt ganz schön rum. Kommt ganz schön rum. Die sehen ordentlich was von der Erde. Mehr als du. Aber ist das nicht eigentlich das schlimmste Gefühl, wenn du so in der ISS bist und nach einem Tag so gar nicht mehr aus dem Fenster guckst? Ja. Ist das nicht eigentlich denn ... Dann holst du auch den Nintendo Switch raus und spielst. Das ist nicht die grösste Enttäuschung. Ace Attorney. Weil du denkst so, ja, ich sehe halt jede halbe Stunde sehe ich die Sahara, den Regenwald, Mount Everest und die chinesische Mauer. Und irgendwann hat man es halt auch. So, jetzt next. So, weiter, können wir zum Saturn mal? Saturn? Ja, und dann kommt er nach Hause und du sagst Hey Schatz, ich dachte nächstes Jahr mal irgendwie an Urlaub in den Tropen. Wie, wäre das was für dich? Urlaub in den Tropen? Und der Typ ist einfach quasi genäher von allen. Scheiß Tropen, ey, kann ich nicht mehr sehen. Ja, okay, wir können auch, ich dachte vielleicht, oder irgendwie Israel oder ein bisschen Wüste. Oh, nee, nee, sorry, aber das wirklich, das hängt mir zum Hals raus, diese Scheiss Pyramiden, ich kann es nicht mehr sehen. Na, die bekannten Pyramiden von Israel. Ich kann es nicht mehr sehen, der grosse Turm von Israel, so gross ist der nicht, sorry, Schatz, wenn wir uns da mal, nee. Oder vielleicht, Sibirien finde ich auch mal irgendwie schön schön. Liebling, ich habe Sibirien, ich kenne das in und aus, ich kenne jeden Quadratmeter, okay? Okay, wo willst du denn dann in Urlaub? Mal schön in den Keller. Mond. Ich wollte ja eigentlich hier, Armstrong wollte ich ja eigentlich ins Lenkrad greifen, dass wir mal schön irgendwie zum Saturn fahren. Wollte er nicht. Nee. Hat er gesagt, nein, dürfen wir nicht. Er hat gesagt, wir sind Astronauten, wir dürfen alles. Was glaubst du denn, wer soll uns denn aufhalten? Die Weltraumpolizei kommt dann hier so, so Tüterter, so einen Streifenwagen angefahren und verhaftet uns. Wir können machen, was wir wollen. Die können die auch fernstellen, können die euch doch. Nein, wenn wir das übersteuern hier. Echt? Hatte die ein Augs-Kabel?
Wir hatten ein Augs-Kabel, ja, aber das hatte hier unser russischer Kollege ständig.
Und das ist ja auch wahnsinnig.
Das ist ja auch wahnsinnig.
Ein sehr stereotyper Russe, der den ganzen Tag die Tetris-Musik hört.
Boah, ich kann es nicht mehr sehen, ey.
Was klingt daran so russisch?
Ist das nicht so russisch? Auf jeden Fall, es ist wahnsinnig russisch. Ja, okay. Aber was klingt daran so russisch? Man kann sich diesen richtigen russischen Tanz vorgut vorstellen. Was für ein russischer Tanz? Dieser Kosaken-Kosaken-Tanz? Das ist einer meiner Lieblingsblicke von dir, dieser Gest du jetzt nicht ein bisschen in zu tiefes Wasser, mein Lieber?
Geh nicht in zu tiefes Wasser.
Schwängt er jetzt an zu schwimmen oder geh wieder zurück?
Das ist auch eine gute Frage, wann fängt man an zu schwimmen, wenn es mehr geht?
Wann gehst du so weit runter, dass du anfängst zu schwimmen?
Ich bin jemand, der erst, weil irgendwann liest es lächerlich aus, weil zu viel Widerstand deinem Körper entgegenschwemmt, dass du dann diesen, du gehst noch, du gehst noch, müsstest aber eigentlich schon schwimmen, aber zu früh schwimmen ist auch merkwürdig, weil dann, wenn du mit den Knien im Wasser bist, ist es auch seltsam. Ja, das stimmt, obwohl die Saison beginnt ja bald wieder und da, ja, sorry, ich muss, sorry, ich will einfach professioneller und der preis für das beste wortspiel 2020 geht an florentin will für saison oh danke schön danke ich bleib sitzen können die den Könnt ihr ihn zu mir bringen? Hier, Achtung, ich werfe ihn. Ich fange, Achtung, Achtung, schwerer Preis.
Ja, ich habe bereit.
Oh, oh, oh, sorry, oh, sorry. Oh, fuck, sorry, oh nein. Geht's dir gut, geht's dir gut? Caroline Kebelkurs ist unmächtig. Oh nein, geht's dir gut? Fuck, Karo, Karo, Karolin, das ist kein Traum, was sie wohl gerade denkt. Irgendwas Lustiges bestimmt. Naja, rufen wir in Krankenwagen. Und es gibt ja nichts Schöneres, als unter Wasser zu laufen. Also so, die Menschen sehen deinen Kopf und denken, der schwimmt, aber nein, ich laufe. Ja, genau. Ich laufe. Ich mache oft die Armbewegungen des Schwimmens, aber gehe dabei, da bin ich ganz offen. Das ist so ein bisschen wie diese Lauffahrräder, die keine Pedale haben, wo Kinder dann drauflaufen. Das ist auch so ein Hybrid, so eine Chimäre der Natur. Man kriegt es nicht genau zusammen im Kopf. Du läufst und hast einen Lenker in der Hand. Das ist jetzt dein Leben. Du brauchst theoretisch kein Lenkrad, weil du kannst ja auch laufen, rechts laufen. Du brauchst theoretisch das Fahrrad nicht, weil du kannst auch einfach laufen.
Du kannst aber auch beim Laufen einfach einen Lenker in die Hand nehmen.
Wenn dir es Sicherheit gibt, kannst du einfach dich denken lassen.
Aber was ich mache, normalerweise, ich gehe in den See bis zu den Oberschenkeln.
Dann vergehen schon mal so gute 17 Minuten, in denen ich Mut aufbaue.
Nee, in denen du mit so einer Dose, so einer Cola-Dose da stehst, mit Shirt aber auch,
und dann in die Sonne guckst und denkst,
Gott sei Dank geht's morgen wieder zurück.
Warum gibt es
so viele fucking Fliegen auf der Welt?
Und dann machst du so diesen Schirm
über den Augenbrauen, was nicht viel
hilft, was nichts hilft,
und dann guckst du dich so um und dann denkst du,
Sonnenbrille vergessen.
Dann mache ich es nämlich, dass ich dann schon bei kniehohem Wasser ein Hecht mache und komplett ins Wasser gehe, damit ich das kalte Wasser hinter mir habe. Ich verpasse es immer oder bin zu früh. Ich verpasse den optimalen Moment. Heißt, meistens bin ich, entweder gehe ich zu früh, dann ist mein Wasser, geht mir gerade bis zu den Knien und ich gehe schon unter und dann sind die Wellen noch zu stark und ich werde wieder an den Strand gespült und strande dann da. Und dann müssen Leute mit so Wassereimern Wasser auf mich drauf spritzen und dann kommt so ein Kran angefahren, der mich dann wieder ins Wasser hiebt. Genau, so ein Bagger, Bagger Schaufel. Genau. Aber was, was ich finde, auch immer kritisch ist, ist der Anlegemoment, wenn du vom Gewässer ans Ufer schwimmst und du weißt so. Ich lasse schon versuchen, den Boden zu erreichen? Ich strande. Weil nichts ist peinlicher, als wenn du schwimmst und dann denkst, ah, jetzt versuche ich auf den Boden zu stellen und ein Fuss geht ins Leere. Es hat immer was von Inception, finde ich, wo man dann so, wenn die in Paris sind und die eine Stadt klappt sich so um und dann gehen sie diesen 90Winkel lang. Und so ist es ein bisschen so, wenn du ankommst, wenn du schwimmst zum Land und dann kommt da unten das Wasser, der Sand und dann kommt es dieser Moment, wo du, das fühlt sich unnatürlich an, wo du dann anfängst zu gehen, wo du so nach vorne klappst und gehst nochmal. Kriegt man nicht hin. Wie so ein Fallschirmspringer, der so landet und dann schon bevor er auf dem Boden ankommt diese Laufbewegung macht. Wie so ein Hund, den man in die Luft hebt und der dann denkt, der kann durch die Luft laufen, der trottelt. Wie fucking dumm kann man sein? Dumme Hunde. Du kannst ja nicht durch Luft laufen, Depp, Alter. Das hast du gestern auch versucht. Das versuchst du auch immer wieder. Im Kettenkarussell versuchst du es auch. Machen wir uns nichts vor.
Hast du im Kettenkarussell schon mal die Schwimmbewegung gemacht? Klar, das ist peinlich. Da kommst du nicht mehr gut von. Kommst du nicht raus. Bist du schnell auch. Weil das funktioniert. Ich hatte so fucking Angst im Kettenkarussell. Warum? Von den Ketten? Einfach so Angst. Ich hatte immer Angst, weil das ist halt so wie so ein Katapult.
Das ist halt, könnte dafür gebaut sein, dass die Ketten irgendwann sich lösen und die Kinder möglichst weit wegfliegen. Und dann irgendwie ist es zu Ende und dann so, oh wollen wir nochmal und ich drehe in den Augen. Nochmal Angst einfach. Aber weil ich vorhin meinte, ob du Notizen nimmst, weil ich hatte heute ein langes Telefonat und er hat mir überlegt, ob ich Notizen nehmen soll. Nehmen. Notizen nehmen, ja. Notizen machen. Man kann Notizen nehmen. Wie willst du den nehmen? Naja, bin ich jetzt auch wieder bei Take oder was? Take Notes. Take Notes? No. Make Notes. Don't take notes, make notes.
Stefan Tietze, Stefan Tietze Inc.
Die hundert verwirrendsten Motivationssprüche von Stefan Tietze. Don't take notes, make notes.
Und dann so ein viel zu selbstbewusstes Bild, dafür, dass ich nicht genau weiß, was ich da gerade gesagt habe.
Don't be a note, make note.
Make a note.
Und tatsächlich, das ist ja so ein klassisches Uni-Ding, du kommst in die Universität, erstes Semester, denkst, okay, ich bin der beste Student der Welt, ich mache Notizen, ich habe irgendwie diesen pinken Marker. Moleskine-Buch. Moleskine. Und im Grunde überlegt man eigentlich die gesamte Vorlesung nur, was soll ich als Notiz schreiben, war die Notiz gerechtfertigt oder hätte ich mir die auch sparen können? Und fuck, jetzt habe ich angefangen zu kritzeln. Jetzt habe ich angefangen zu kritzeln. Und im Grunde denke mir immer so und der professor sagt irgendwas schlaues nicht mehr soll ich das als notiz schreiben jetzt kann ich mir merken oder wenn ich mir notiz schreibe kann ich mir wahrscheinlich dann weniger merken weil mein gehirn sagt na ich habe notiz geschrieben auf der anderen seite kann ich so nachlesen ja das ist geht die gesamte vorlesung so und am ende habe ich nichts gelernt was haben sie gesagt ein notiz gemacht können sie noch mal alles wiederhol noch mal alles wiederholen? Können Sie noch mal die ganze Stunde wiederholen? Und wenn immer so diese eine Meldung, Entschuldigung, gibt es alles, was Sie gerade gesagt haben, noch mal im Internet so? Ja, es gibt einen Pädel. Genau wie die grössten Fehler von Dozenten bei uns auch aus der Uni war immer, am Anfang der Stunde zu sagen, dass es diese ganze Präsentation auch online gibt. Ja, die Hälfte der Klasse steht auf dem Kfen. Und ohne Scheiss alle direkt dieses, ah, so eine Last von den Leuten fällt. So, ich muss diese nächste Stunde, muss ich nichts machen, nichts wird von mir verlangt. Hast du schon mal so einen Textmarker benutzt, so diesen Neongrünen? Ich markiere aber auch immer, ja, aber ich bin dazu, ich hink da auch dann zu visuell, ästhetisch und will dann, ich kann es zum Beispiel nicht ertragen, wenn die wichtigsten Informationen immer zu der rechts stehen, dann muss ich auch mal was links markieren, damit das ganze Bild aufgeräumter ist. Und du hoffst dann, bitte lass die interessanten Sachen jetzt links stehen. Links stehen, das ist zu unausgeglichen. Das ist viel zu unausgeglichen. Ja, deswegen, ich will regelmäßig markieren. Ja. Dadurch vergesse ich dann meistens immer, was wichtig ist eigentlich. Aber du hast die Notizen gemacht heute mit dem langen Telefonat? Ja, ich habe die Notizen gemacht, ich weiß nicht, vielleicht, ich habe die Notizen gemacht, ein paar Sachen aufgeschrieben, aber ich bin, ich gehe dann auch, glaube ich, zu gackig dran, ich schreibe dann halt die lustigen Sachen auf so, und das ist halt nicht der Sinn der Sache eigentlich, aber immerhin. Und ich meine, noch nie hat sich jemand Notizen dann noch mal angeguckt. Man macht das einfach fürs Gewissen und weiß, okay, ich weiß es zwar nicht, aber die Notizen sind irgendwo, darauf kann ich mich verlassen. Hast du es auch gemacht, ein bisschen um der anderen Person zu gefallen? War es ein Videocall? Hat die Person gesehen? Es war ein Telefonat und ich habe tatsächlich einmal versucht, das Handy so nah an das Papier zu halten, dass man hört, dass ich mitschreibe, weil ich mir dachte, dass die Person dann denkt, oh, der schreibt mit. Auf der anderen Seite hätte es natürlich auch so kritzeln sein können oder so, oh, ist die doof oder sowas schreibe ich. Entschuldigung, Herr Will, ich habe da irgendwie so ein ... Hm? Ich mache einen Tiefsinn. Ach so, das müssen Sie nicht, es gibt ein Handout. Das Geräusch von zergrüsseltem Papier. Ja, genau. Zerknüllen. In wie viele Stücke hast du das Blatt Papier zerrissen, das du in die meisten Stücke zerrissen hast in deinem Leben? Bist du so ein Doppelriss in vier Stücke? Das sind diese Fragen, die mir immer stellst, die nicht aufgelöst werden, die sehr unbefriedigend sind. Genau wie letzte Woche die Frage, wann die erste Google-Domain zum Kauf steht. Wie viele O's müsste man Google schreiben, bis sie zum Verkauf steht? Ich habe gesagt, 51 war, glaube ich, die falsche Antwort. Ich glaube, es war neun. Irgendjemand hat sich die Domain mit neun Os gekauft. Herzlichen Glückwunsch. Jetzt von unseren Hörern? Ja, ja, hat jemand auf Twitter gepostet, dem gehört jetzt die G9 Os 50 Euro? Ja, ich weiß es nicht. Er meinte, der will sie weiterverkaufen mit 50 Euro. Google mit neun Os, fantastisch. Ja, ist richtig gut. Aber man muss schon echt bescheuert sein, dass man da aus Versehen draufkommt. Muss man auch mal sagen. Wie heisst die Seite? Google, okay. G-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U-U- Ja, war doch geil, wenn auf den Visitenkarten Google mit neuen O steht.
Das stimmt eigentlich schon. Mail, Kontakt, at, Google. Naja, das habe ich so aufgeregt. Ja, ich würde behaupten, so 154. 154. Musstest du schon mal Dokumente vernichten? Tatsächlich müssen von Netflix aus, ist es eine Vorgabe, dass alle alten Skripte in so einen Papierwolf kommen, bevor sie in den Papiercontainer gehen. Echt? Damit nicht verrückte Fans, und es gibt ja tausende verrückte Fans, die unbedingt wissen wollen, wie es mit The Auto Cell Drive Online-Fast weitergeht, die dann vor den Papiercontainern der BTF wieder rumlungern und in meinem Papier zu Hause alte Skripte suchen, erste Fassungen suchen. Und deswegen müsste es geschreddert werden, bevor es dann in den Container kommt. Und hast du auch privat so einen Wolf? Nee. Nee, privat zerreisse ich das so und dann esse ich zwischendurch auch so ein Stück Papier, wie man das kennt aus Filmen. und dann mischst du die auch so in unterschiedliche Haufen. Ich meine, da sind wir natürlich wieder leider direkt bei unserem alten Thema Argo. Wo ja Argo, falls ihr den Film nicht kennt, die Geschichte ist die, Diplomaten müssen in kurzer Zeit ganz viele Akten vernichten. Ja. Und das ist ein Teilplatz. Verlieben sich Menschen, es viel Spaß,
es gibt eine Musiknummer, es gibt eine Musikmontage.
Und vor allem, die haben, also ich weiß nicht,
ob das historisch korrekt ist, aber ich gehe mal davon aus,
weil das würde man sich wahrscheinlich nicht ausdenken,
die haben in der Botschaft
haben die einen Ofen,
der speziell
dafür gedacht ist, dass damit Dokumente
verbrannt werden, falls ganz schnell sämtliche Dokumente vernichtet werden. Ja, eigentlich schon so. Genau diese eine Szene aus Dark Knight, die ich nie verstanden habe, wie der Fingerabdruck rekonstruiert wurde aus dem Einschussloch. Ja, ja. Und so, das ist so im letzten, Richtung Akt drei geht es ja schon. Ja. So, und dann gibt's diese berühmte Szene unten in diesem weissen Keller, wo diese Kanone in drei verschiedene Wände schlägt. Dann, so, dann durchsuchen sie das, Alfred ruft irgendwas mit, with great power comes the great responsibility, und Christian Bale fährt davon und sagt, ja, aber das verdient Gotham. So, im Prinzip The Dark Knight in a nutshell, Megafilm, acht Oscars, alle Oscars, bitte. Und niemand hinterfragt jemals, wie haben die denn jetzt den Fingerabdruck rekonstruieren können von dem Einschussloch? Also ich verstehe, wie Sie gesagt, wir meint haben, wie der Fingerabdruck auf das Projektil kommt. Weil du hast ja diese Patronenhülse, also du hast die Hülse mit dem Projektil, das vorne drin steckt. Du hast diese Bronze Hülle, wo das Schwarzpulver drin ist. Das hat doch keinen Einfluss auf das Einschussloch. So, aber dann, wenn du jetzt zum Beispiel diese Patrone in ein Magazin drückst von oben, dann ist dein Fingerabdruck auf dem Projektil vorne drauf. Und dann, wenn das Projektil geschossen wird, dann ist es ja im Einschussloch. Aber das Projektil selber haben die nicht. Sie haben dann nur im Einschussloch die Fingerabdruckfeste. Er hat das Einschussloch rausgeschnitten, mitgenommen, as you do, und dann versuchst. Was haben Sie da? Nichts, Stück Wand. Wie ein Stück Wand? Können Sie nicht mehr stehen bleiben, können Sie nicht stehen bleiben, stehen bleiben. Er ist in einem riesigen schwarzen Auto weggefahren. Und so Bergmobil bei Mac Drive, einfach mal so, ne, mein, wo man alles mitnimmt. Ein Fisch, Mac, Fisch, Mac, die heissen nur Filiofisch. Fisch. Zum Hinterhaken. Und also ich glaube, die Idee ist tatsächlich, dass die Fettreste vom Finger im Einschussloch zurückbleiben. Aber es ist schon, du hast schon recht, es ist schon sehr konstruiert. Das ist an den Haaren herbeigezogen. Aber es ist trotzdem ein cooler Film. Wir mögen es. Aber du hast recht, Ar Argo und ich habe wieder ein Bild bekommen, wie jemand DVDs auf der Strasse gefunden hat und wieder war nur Argo über. Und es ist wahre, ich finde es fantastisch. Ist das so ein Insider-Gag mittlerweile, dass alle Argo liegen lassen? Warum lassen alle Argo liegen? Oder haben alle Argo schon geguckt? Leg mal Argo auf die Strasse. Jeder Mensch, der einen DVD oder Blu-Ray-Player hat, hat Argo schon gesehen.
Und die Streaming-Freaks, die brauchen keine DVD oder Blu-Ray. Das stimmt. Aber wir haben ungenöste Fragen. Du hast mir eine Aufgabe gegeben, die mich sehr gefreut hat. Oh ja, also wo wir schon bei 20 Jahre alten Filmen sind, geht es direkt weiter. Tatsächlich, schon sehr alt. 2005 war, glaube ich, kam der erste Flutterkaribik raus oder sowas. Wir sind die beiden grössten Flucht-Ergebeck-Freaks, die ich persönlich kenne.
Und jetzt ist bestimmt die Hälfte von euch stöhnt auf und skippt 50 Sekunden vor. Genau, schreibt gerne in die Kommentare auf der Website, bis wohin man skippen muss für den Flucht-Ergebeck-Talk, damit man den überspringen kann.
Genau, weil wir haben ja die grossen Lost-Woche aus, die Flucht-Ergebeck-Wochen eingeläutet.
Wir haben über Commodore Norrington gesprochen. Richtig. Wir haben über, wir haben über, was es heißt, Lieutenant zu sein in Zeiten von der Besatzung von Jamaica. Keine Korrektur, es kam keine Korrektur, keine pedantische, nö, es kam aber auch davor gar keine Frage auf, also es war, es es ist euch völlig egal offensichtlich. Das heißt, entweder liege ich richtig oder wir haben schlicht keine Hörer mehr. Oder es ist so falsch, dass es Leuten zu aufwendig ist, es zu korrigieren. Governor Swann haben wir besprochen und wie die im Verhältnis steht. Könnt ihr gerne in den letzten Wochen nochmal nachhören. Oder nicht. Hier ist nochmal der Ausschnitt von letzter Woche. So, und du hast mir die Aufgabe, übrigens, was ich beim Nachgucken der Filme jetzt, was mir aufgefallen ist, ist, dass es natürlich noch Lord Beckett gibt, Abteil drei, glaube ich, oder zwei. Ach, Lord Beckett. Oh Gott, Lord. Und von dir wünsche ich mir, dass du nächste Woche sagst, wo denn der Lord da reinlässt. denn der Lord da rein und letztendlich einfach Gott. Von dir kam die Aufgabe, genau noch mal zu erklären, wie denn der Fluch des Cortes reinspielt in die Filme, wie er genau funktioniert und wo das denn sein Anker eine Realität hat. Und zwar basiert es auf Hernan Cortez, nicht Cortez, sondern Cortez, weil es ist das S mit S geschrieben und nicht mit Z geschrieben. Nein, es ist Hernan Cortez und den kennt man ja wirklich, den gab es ja auch wirklich. Der hat nämlich, der wurde von der spanischen Royal Navy losgeschickt, um Südamerika zu erforschen und gewissermaßen zu unterjochen. Der hat dann angefangen, er ist mit 15 Schiffen los, also wirklich eine 500 Mann starke Besatzung, auch einige Pferde dabei, also ordentlich aufgebrochen, um zu kolonialisieren. Also das war von Anfang an die Idee. Ernan Cortes war der Chef von dem ganzen Land, von der ganzen Flotte, weiss nicht genau wie seine Position war, ich glaube er war auch sogar wie Marquise, Markgraf würde man im Deutschen sagen, der ist jedenfalls dann losgeschickt worden und hat dann die Halbinsel Yucatan, heutiges Mexiko, bereist, hat dann da die Maya getroffen, die aber in Ruhe gelassen, ist dann weiter und hat irgendwann die Azteken um Montezuma herum getroffen. Und hat er irgendwas Bestimmtes gesucht oder einfach mal so geguckt? Ne, also sein Ziel war es einfach, das einzunehmen, Südamerika einzunehmen. Der hat auch später Honduras eingenommen, wurde dann vom König Karl II. und so geehrt und so. Wusstest du, dass die Habsburger mit den Spaniern auch angewandelt haben? Was wusste ich alles gar nicht. Wusste ich nicht tatsächlich. Auch alles spannend.
Hernán Cortes kam also an, hat die Mayanruhe gelassen, hat dann die Azteken gefunden, hat sich dann mit Montezuma auch eingelassen und so, aber nach ein paar Jahre gut, glaube ich, und dann ist er den Rücken gefallen und hat dann angefangen, die Azteken abzuschlachten und zu unterjochen, um dann das ganze Gebiet einzunehmen, heutiges Mexico City, da so die Ecke. Und der wurde wahnsinnig bluthungrig, galt als wahnsinnig gierig und hat dann da furchtbare Schandtaten getrieben und hat dann die quasi die Azteken ausgelöscht. Später auch, glaube ich, noch wirklich Honduras eingenommen usw. Wurde dann wahnsinnig toll geehrt. Mit seinen 500 Leuten. Genau, irgendwann waren es wahrscheinlich mehr. Montezuma wurde aber von den eigenen Leuten irgendwie umgebracht, weil er dann, keine Ahnung, Verrat wurde ihm vorgebracht, keine Ahnung. Ist auch alles nicht so wichtig. In der Adaption, in der Fiktionalisierung von Futurkaribik spricht man von dem Fluch des Cortes. Da wurde nämlich dann von den Azteken eine Truhe, eine Steintruhe mit 882 Münzen, Goldmünzen, ihm geschenkt als Blutgeld im Sinne von, das kriegst du jetzt von uns und dann ist gut, um seine Gier zu stillen.
Aber das hat das Gegenteil mit ihm ausgelöst, nämlich erst hat er diese Truhe angenommen, hat dann aber weiter noch Bluttaten, Schandtaten getrieben und wurde quasi noch gieriger und wollte immer mehr Reichtum anhäufen. Es hat ihm alles nicht gereicht und dann weitergemacht. Und das hat die heidnischen Götter dann so sehr entzürnt, dass er da immer noch gierig ist, dass sie diese Truhe mit einem Fluch belegt haben. Und seitdem werden alle Leute zu Untoten, die aus dieser Truhe etwas herausnehmen. Das ist die tatsächliche Geschichte mit dem Untoten. Nein, das ist alles fictionalisiert. Genau, also alles mit dieser Truhe ist fictionalisiert. Also es gibt für diese Truhen-Geschichten keine realistische Legende oder Mythos oder so was?
Nein, außer dass er wahnsinnig gierig war
und diese ganzen Aztekenschätze halt geklaut hat.
Ach so, also das hat sich komplett fluch der Griebig ausgedacht.
Ich glaube schon.
Okay, krass.
Ich freue mich auf eure Korrekturen.
Aber das ist alles ausgedacht.
882 habe ich nicht genau herausgefunden,
warum diese Zahl so ein Bewandtnis hat.
Ja, das wäre natürlich gut.
Was heißt 882 auf Aztekisch? Kannst du das kurz?
Gier. Gier. Aber da habe ich jetzt keinen Zusammenhang entdeckt.
Jedenfalls ist der Schatzer verflucht von den heidnischen Göttern.
Unter anderem Theadalma ist ja die, später die Kalypso, ist ja auch eine heidnische Göttin, die Meeresgöttin.
Die spielt dann in Teil 3 eine grössere Rolle. Ich freue mich wahnsinnig, dass wir diese Rubrik haben und man lernt wahnsinnig viel. Und in Jukatan war ich ja schon, das hat mich sehr gefreut. Aber ich meine, Fluch der Kribik basiert ja ursprünglich auf einer Achterbahn. Ja, das heißt, gab es diesen ganzen Fluch des Cortez-Dings schon in der Achterbahn? Ich bin mir sicher, dass es den Cortez-Fluch in der Achterbahn schon gab. Es ist fantastisch, eine Adaption von der Achterbahn zu machen. Und die Achterbahn hat dann, okay, Skelettpiraten wegen Fluch und dann Filmen rausgemacht. Aber es ist nicht eine sehr schlechte Adaption einer Achterbahn. Wo ist das? Hochbahn, wo ist das? Oh, wo ist das Looping?
Ich würde mir wahnsinnig, gibt es diese noch, die Achterbahn wahrscheinlich nicht mehr, oder?
Ich war schon sehr lange nicht mehr Disney World, muss ich.
Da würde ich gerne mal hin und die mir angucken, die mal einmal fahren.
Es gibt ja, in Disney World gibt es ja eine Streichelzone, der mega unbeliebt ist, den niemand interessiert, aber anscheinend. Stell dir vor, du bist eine Ziege im Streichelko, aber in Disney World.
Genau, und anscheinend war das früher mal ein grösseres Ding und die hatten auch mehr Tiere und das war halt irgendwie eine der Attraktionen, dass man da Tiere sehen konnte. Aber mittlerweile wurde es so stark reduziert, dass es halt nur noch ein paar Ziegen gibt. Das heißt, du kannst dir überlegen, will ich jetzt irgendwie die krasseste Achterbahn der Welt fahren, Mickey Mouse treffen oder die Ziege streicheln? Will ich Space Mountain 2 fahren oder Ziege streicheln? Aber unsere gute Freundin Jenny Nicholson, wir empfehlen auch immer die beiden gleichen Personen, immer Adam Neely und Jenny Nicholson. Und Jenny Nicholson hat nämlich mal so ein Video gemacht, das fantastisch ist. Ich liebe ja eh ihre Videos, die gemacht hat so The Ten Lamest Things You Can Do at Disney World. Und das ist ein fantastisches Video. Und da ist sie auch bei dem Streichel zu. Und guckt euch das auf jeden Fall an. Kenne ich gar nicht, freue ich mich drauf. Ja, ich freue mich sehr, gleich nach Hause zu fahren, um Fluchte Rebe 2 zu gucken. Ja, du hast da mehr Optimismus. Und 3. Ich habe die tatsächlichen weiteren Teile sehr schlecht in Erinnerung. Die sind auch nicht so geil, aber ich liebe die Welt. Ich glaube, die Welt war schlechter, ich glaube der zweite, weil du hast dann so die Davy Jones und so. Aber das gibt es schon, ne Davy Jones. Das ist eine echte Piratenlegende. Da freue ich mich auf dein Referat. Über Davy Jones. Davy Jones. Und die Flying Dutchman natürlich auch. Oh ja, ja, das können wir gerne machen, da so ein bisschen in diese Piraten, wie sagt man, Garen? Nee, Seemannsgaren. Seemannsgaren. Ja. Da einzusteigen. Man sieht auch wirklich, wie sie sich am Anfang, wie sie beim ersten Film so eine Liste gemacht haben mit Dingen, also mit Piraten-Klischees.
Dinge, die wir besprechen müssen. Seemannsgarn, Frauen bringen Unglück, diese ganzen Skelett-Schatztruhe, über die Planke gehen, mal einmal alles überlegt hat, genau, dann Barbossa, der ja kein Bein hat, sondern ... Ja, genau, dann Äffchen, Papagei.
Genau, einmal alles aufgeschrieben, verflucht, schwarze Segel, einmal mal kurz alles aufgeschrieben. So entstehen die besten Filme einfach so, Liste mit was ist geil. Und dann abarbeiten. Und dann einfach abarbeiten. Was wollen wir sehen? Ja. Was wollen wir denn sehen? Ja. Fantastisch. 882. Und die müssen alle Münzen zurücksammeln und ihr Blut geben und dann können sie den Fluch brechen.
Richtig, dann ist alles zurückgegeben und das Blutgeld zurückgezahlt. Auf jeden Fall. Aber wenn ich einen Tipp geben kann an junge Autoren da draußen, dann macht euch, bevor ihr richtig in ein Projekt einsteigt, immer eine Liste mit Dingen, auf die man Bock hat. Weil das sind die Dinge, die man aus dem Auge verliert sofort, wenn dann sowas reinkickt wie, ja, aber die Charaktere müssen klarer gegeneinander aufgestellt werden, aber das muss verändert werden, weil das passt dazu nicht und hier ballert irgendwie, es kann man den Ort nicht nehmen, weil der undrehbar ist und hier muss man Kompromiss eingehen, da muss man Kompromiss eingehen, die Figur muss ein Mann werden, die Figur muss eine Frau werden. Es kommt so viel Realismus irgendwann rein, automatisch von allen Seiten, dass man oft dann die Dinge aus dem Auge verliert, um die es eigentlich geht, warum man sich erst in die Idee verliebt hat. Und das sind die Dinge, die so viel Spaß machen ja eigentlich auch, die sich auch übertragen. Und dann bist immer noch du der Idealist im Raum, der sagt, ich will meine Schneeballschlacht. Ja, aber Stefan, wir drehen im Sommer, das ergibt, nein, ich will die Schneeballschlacht, ich will diese Szene, wo sie einen dicken roten Schal hat und dann kriegt sie einen Schneeball ins Gesicht, guckt, erst mal verwirrt, guckt sich oben. Aber das geht nicht, auf meine Liste! Da steht er am anderen Ende, lacht und dann am Ende liegen sie zusammen im Schnee. Ich will diese Szene. Es steht auf meiner Liste. Es steht auf meiner Liste. Was steht noch auf der Liste? Da steht Schneeballschlacht. Sonst nichts. Du bist gerade an den Laptop gekommen, aber er nimmt weiterhin auf. Alles gut. Was war es gerade für eine Referenz? Den kann man sich verlassen. Es steht auf meiner Liste. Ohne, das ist nur eine Turmmelodie-Referenz. Kill Bill? Es steht auf meiner Liste. Ohne, das ist jetzt, das ist nur eine Tor-Melodie-Referenz. Äh, Kill Bill? Es steht auf meiner Liste. Oh, ist das, ist das Helikotter? Nee, ich sag den Originaltext. Warte mal. Geh weg und komm nie wieder. Geh weg und komm nie wieder. Ja, das ist Gollum. Gollum. Muss ich jetzt aber auch mal ein bisschen nachdenken. Und ich kann den Flugzeugergebik 1 komplett mitsprechen, muss man auch einfach mal sagen. Komplett. Allein der ganze Dialog, wie er mit den beiden Soldaten, wie Jack Sparrow am Anfang mit den beiden Soldaten auf dem Schiff, auf dem Steg
spricht, weil er aufs Schiff geht, wenn er es kapern will.
Den ganzen Dialog kann ich einzeln
besprechen. Ich finde es toll, dass wir
ihn schon so lange kennen und schon so lange einen Podcast
machen und erst jetzt merken, dass unsere
grösste Leidenschaft nur der Kaline ist.
Wie so eine Ehe, die schon so vier Jahre
lang eingeschlafen war und man merkt,
dass man irgendwie den gleichen Fetisch hat.
Moment, das fahren wir ja jetzt erst?
Und was wir in einer der nächsten Wochen mal machen werden, ist, wir werden einen Film gucken zusammen. Oder nicht? Ja, können wir gerne machen. Meine absolute Lieblingsszene ist, wo Jack Sparrow dann dieses eine Schiff kapert und die auf der Dauntless hinterherfahren und dann dieser eine Adjutant von Norring. Nee, nee, die fahren auf der Interceptor hinterher und dann klauen sie die Interceptor, weil das ja das schnellste Schiff ist, vermeintlich. Und dann dieser Adjutant von Commodore Norrington sagt, this has to be the best part I've ever seen. Und Norrington einfach so völlig vernichtet. So it would seem. So it would seem. So it would seem. Einfach so vernichtet einfach. Aber er muss anerkennen. Ist das Gillette? Gillette. Es gibt noch Gillette. So it would seem. Gillette brennt die Eisen. Einer der Leute heißt Gillette. Ach so, ich dachte schon, ich dachte, das ist der Werbeklaim von Gillette. Gillette brennt die Eisen. So it would seem Können wir da noch mal rüber gucken über den Claim? Ich habe nicht ganz verstanden. Nee, Gillette ist ja eine der Figuren, die da sind. Ja, brennend Gillette? Ja. Also es gibt ja so oft in Filmen diese lustigen Zwei, diese Bickering, die so ein bisschen auflockern. Bei Star Wars ist es eher Z Dezo und C-3-VO. Aber Fluchtegrippik hat interessanterweise zwei von diesen Pärken. Die beiden Piraten. Die haben die Piraten Rigetti und den anderen. Aber wir haben auch noch mal von der Royal Navy diese beiden Soldaten, die auch immer bickern. Also wir haben Doppelbicker. Alle drei Teilen vorkommen. Und von der Piratenbesatzung bestimmt auch, oder? Ja. Also toll, einfach noch mal, ich will einfach zwei Bickering Pairs, gib mir zwei, ich will noch mehr haben. Toll, das war tatsächlich einer meiner ersten DVDs, habe ich hundertmal geguckt, auch das Bonusmaterial ganz oft geguckt, das Blooper Reel, das war das erste Blooper Reel, das ich in meinem Leben gesehen habe, war Fluch der Karibik, wo man erstmal checkt, also du guckst ja so einen Film und denkst dir, das ist halt Magie, das ist eine fremde Welt als Kind, aber das erste Mal, dass du so einen Blooper-Reel siehst und so Outtakes, mit die Schauspieler müssen lachen und so, ich war weggeblasen, ich dachte mir, wie fucking cool ist das? Es gibt Leute, deren Job ist es, da irgendwo auf so einem Steg zu stehen, am Wasser und mit so einem Papagei zu sprechen und das war fantastisch. Ja, voll. Ganz, ganz großartig. Hat dich Fluttergarebig also zum Film gebracht? Hat dich das zum Schauspieler gemacht? Weiß ich nicht. Kann sein, aber ich war begeistert und auch natürlich mein großer Held Orlando Bloom. Ich hatte zwei große Leidenschaften, Herr der Ringe und Fluttergarebig, und in beiden war Orlando Bloom. Ja, fantastisch. Einer der schönsten Männer der Welt. Vielleicht der schönste Mann der Welt, ja. Kann man wirklich nicht sagen. Du hast ein bisschen was von Orlando Bloom. Oh, das ist nett von dir, danke. Wirklich? Na ja, die Haare. Ja. Nee, du hast ein bisschen was. Irgendwann müssen wir auch über Königreich der Himmel reden, aber das ist noch ein anderes Thema. Komm. Das ist noch ein anderes Thema. Das kriegen wir auch noch hin. Ja, das war unsere
Futurimik-Ecke für heute.
Sehr schön. Wir brauchen eigentlich, also falls ihr
Lust habt, einen kleinen Jingle zu komponieren
und euch so ein bisschen mit
Jerry Brookheimer anzulegen.
Fakten.
Futurimik-Fakten-Ecke.
Toll.
Tolles Franchise.
Ich würde auch gerne mal mit so einer Kanone schießen, ey, das wäre nicht so geil. Ich habe, weil da gibt es ja diese eine Szene, wo sie diese Kanone laden mit diesen zwei Kugeln, die an der Kette hängen. Wo die dann so ein Schleudergeschoss haben, die den Mast durchsäbeln, wo ich tatsächlich mal, ich habe irgendwie so einen Grossonkel oder sowas, der auch eine grosse Waffensammlung hat und so, der sich auskennt, den habe ich gefragt, geht sowas, geht das? Und der meinte, nee. War auch wieder ein Teil kaputt. Viel geht nicht aus diesem Film. Nee, geht nicht. Nö, nee. Nö. Nö. Man will nicht so werden, man will nicht der Erwachsene sein. Nein, man kann differenzieren, man kann ja über Filme reden mit pedantischem historischer Korrektheit, muss das aber trennen von was will ich von dem Film.
Es gibt genug Leute, die das vermischen.
Das flutere Riebig schon pedantisch nah an der Realität.
Ja, natürlich.
Plus Flug. In Port Royal habe ich gegoogelt, heisst jetzt anders.
Ne, habe ich auch gegoogelt, heisst immer noch Port Royal.
Ich bin ein Wetter. Plus Flug. In Port Royal habe ich gegoogelt, heisst jetzt anders. Nee, habe ich auch gegoogelt, heisst immer noch Port Royal. Ah, sowas. Dann okay, nee, dann habe ich gegoogelt und heisst... Aber ist nicht immer die Hauptstadt von Jamaica, Kingston. Ja? Ist die Hauptstadt von Jamaica. Kann, ja. Ja. Aber Port Royal wird immer noch... Man wird immer noch googelt und der andere hat mehr Ahnung davon als man selbst. Wird immer immer noch von Gouverneur Swann regiert. Die Swanns sind bis heute noch an der Macht. Die Swanns, also können wir uns alle mal in den Flieger setzen nach Jamaica und dann mal Gouverneur Swann die Hand schütteln. Gott, ey. Oh mein Gott, ich liebe diesen ... Ich gucke auch nur drei, gefühlt drei Filme in meinem Leben immer. Plutarcharibik, Harry Potter 3 und Herr der Ringe. Immer wieder, weil das sind so schöne Filme, die ich andauernd gucken kann und so. Und die machen mir, ich glaube, ich fühle mich nie so wohl, ich kann mich egal in welcher Situation nicht so wohlfühlen, wie wenn ich Plutarcharibik 1 gucke. Weil das ist so eine ultimative Comfortzone. Absolut, und ich habe ja damals, als Plutarcharibik rausgekommen ist, das war genau in den Ferien, in den Sommerferien, soweit ich mich erinnere. Und das war so, da hatte ich so ein paar Wochen, wo ich nicht in Urlaub war, sondern bei mir zu Hause war. Und ich habe wirklich eine Zeit lang jeden zweiten Tag Fluch der Karibik im Kino angeschaut. Ich habe diesen Film dreizehn mal im Kino gesehen. Dreizehn mal. Was? Ja, weil ich hatte Zeit. Auf Deutsch dann, ne? Ja, auf Deutsch, ja. Ich hatte Zeit und ich fand den Film einfach so geil und dachte mir einfach so, was mache ich heute? Ferien? Ich schaue mir den nochmal an. Und man hat jedes Mal hat man so ein Piratenkopf-Tattoo bekommen an der Kinokasse und ich habe jeden Tag ein neues Tattoo bekommen. Nein. Ja, ich fand das so geil, einfach mir den immer wieder anzugucken. Und irgendwann war ich so, du hast jetzt einfach Teil meines Tages, mir den anzugucken.
Ich musste nicht immer in die Nachbarstadt mit dem Fahrrad
fahren, Film angucken, zack.
Was war die beste Vorstellung?
Weil ich denke mal eins, du bist
amazed weggeflasht. Ja. Guckst du das zweite
Mal und entdeckst neue Sachen und bist
amazed und weggeflasht. Am dritten Mal denkst
du, ja, jetzt reicht's auch
langsam. Ja, nee, nee. Am vierten Mal sagst du, okay, jetzt mach ich ein Thing draus. Nee, ich glaub, es war sowas wie drei, wo du merkst, also normalerweise, wenn man den Film dreimal guckt, denkt man, das war's jetzt, aber wenn du beim dritten Mal noch merkst, nee, den muss ich noch mal sehen, dann merkst du dir, okay, das ist ein besonderer Film. Aber so, wie war dein Gefühl, was war das beste, was war dein Gefühl nach dem achten Mal gewesen? Na, da war es Alltag, da war es einfach, da hab ich, dieses Juwel für mich gefreut. Wann war ein kleiner Tiefpunkt erreicht? Ja, elf war ein kleiner Tiefpunkt, aber dann einfach nochmal die Musik. Und ich bin immer den ganzen Abspann bis zum Ende gesessen, weil ich die Musik immer auch so cool fand. Und fand ich toll. Da habe ich natürlich auch die CD gekauft und hoch und runter gehört. Oh Gott. Alles toll. Gibt es eher Klaus Badelt oder Hans Zimmer die Credits? Nee, eher Klaus Badelt.
Ja, ne?
Ja.
Hans Zimmer ist quasi komplett verschwunden.
Galt mal als der Komponist von Food Rebek 1 irgendwann komplett verschwunden.
Jerry gab es ordentlich Stress.
Nee, das müssen wir auch einmal alle an den runden Tisch zusammenbringen und das mal klären.
Lass uns nächste Woche mal Hans Zimmer anrufen und Klaus Badelt.
Klaus Badelt hat Zimmer, Jerry Bruckheimer und Orlando Bloom an einem Tisch und dann lassen wir das einfach mal irgendwie, lassen wir die einfach mal ausreden. Ja, also so heißt auch das Format. Wir reden auch gar nicht. Einfach mal ausreden lassen, wir halten nur Mikros rein. Aber ja, weil ich glaube nämlich, dass Klaus Badl der bessere Melodie- Komponist ist. Och Stefan, also da weiß ich nicht, ob wir das Thema jetzt nochmal aufmachen müssen. Ja, aber Hans Zimmer, der kann
natürlich sehr gut in Atmosphäre
und so, aber Melodien kommen nicht
so viel von ihm rum. Und Klaus Badelt
ist natürlich der, der war ein Schüler von Hans Zimmer
zu der Zeit auch. Und
Hans Zimmer wollte den Film gar nicht machen.
Hat dann gesagt, Klaus, hast du
nicht Lust, das so zu machen?
Und dann hat Klaus Badelt vor allem
diese ganzen Melodien geschrieben. Und hat den besten
fucking Soundtrack aller Zeiten geschrieben.
Ja.
Danach hat er auch nicht mehr so viel hingekriegt.
Der ist ein bisschen an diesem Konflikt zerbrochen, glaube ich.
Weiss man alles nicht. Wollen wir da mal so eine
kleine Doku machen, da mal so einsteigen in dieses
Komponisten-Welt. Was wirklich geschah. Badelt vs.
Zimmer. Ja.
Das ist ja auch eine gute Idee. Das ist unser Beethoven, das ist der Beethoven unserer Zeit, das ist Klaus Badelt, aber wir ehren den nicht so sehr. Dam, dam, dam, dam. Oh mein Gott! Ich höre mir denn heute auch noch mal, ich höre mir denn noch mal an. Ich will, ich gehe heute noch mal schön ans Meer und höre mir denn noch mal an.
Ich will so ein Floss haben, ich will so ein kleines Floss, eine kleine Gondoliere.
Und einfach mal gucken, wie weit kommt man damit. Ich geh heute noch mal schön ans Meer und hör mir noch mal an. Ich will so ein Floss haben, ich will so ein kleines Floss, eine kleine Gondoliere.
Und einfach mal gucken, wie weit kommt man damit.
Einfach ich mit so einem langen Stock.
Kannst du ja auf einen Reihen setzen.
Aber ist der Reihen nicht sehr tief, braucht man da nicht einen sehr langen Stock?
Wahnsinnig tief und viel zu streisserisch, wie man sagt.
Viel zu provokant, wie der Nautiker sagen will.
Ja. Kann man irgendwie so eine, das ist meine Frage, weil es gibt so Star Wars-Touren und dann kannst du nach Norwegen reisen, wo die Hoth gedreht haben und so. Gibt es so eine Fluchte-Karibik-Tour? So ein Urlaub. Ja, können wir so Fluchte-Karibik-Urlaub machen? Und auch auf die Insel, wo Jack Sparrow hingeschickt wurde? Ja. Und dann wird man da auch einen Tag lang ausgesetzt und so. Und natürlich mit Schatzsuche. Genau, mit Schatzsuche. Es gibt eine Schatzsuche, begraben. Und für Rum gibt es und so. Du trinkst auch Rum, auch wenn du es nicht willst. Naja, so Kinderrum halt so. Kinderrum, ja. Und dann muss man auch so ein Feuer machen, damit dann die Royal Navy einen sieht und findet und so. Mega. Ey, finde ich toll. Wir sind ja immer noch auf der Suche nach unserem großen Abenteuer, was wir starten können. Vielleicht wäre die Karibik ein guter Ort, an dem wir mal anfangen können, einfach mal zu suchen. Ey, im Ernst, gibt's da bestimmt noch alte Schiffswrackwacks, weil da ist die Frage, ob wir da die Richtigen sind, um die mit Taucheranzügen zu untersuchen. Glaube ich nämlich nicht. Ja, Tauchen bin ich skeptisch, ehrlich gesagt. Ich habe irgendwie meine Lust am Tauchen verloren. Ich habe Tauchkurs gemacht, es gibt ja A, B, C und ab C darf man mit Flasche tauchen. Und ich habe A und B gemacht und dann haben mir meine Eltern ein Buch geschenkt, Die Wunder der Meere, wo ich so dermassen hässliche Fische gesehen habe, dass ich gesagt habe, ich will nie wieder ins Wasser gehen. Und habe meine Tauchausbildung abgebrochen und bin nie zum Flaschentauchen gekommen.
Weil ich gesagt habe, ich will nicht in so eine scheiß Moräne reinsteigen oder so einen Steinfisch, diese dreckswiderlichen, hässlichen Viecher, will ich nichts mehr zu tun haben.
Und seitdem bin ich nie wieder ins Wasser gestiegen.
Seitdem bist du nie wieder ins Wasser gestiegen?
Nee.
Badewanne?
Das sind keine Moränen.
Naja, wer weiß.
Okay. Das ist schlechte Voraussetzung für unseren Flutter-Garibik-Schatzsuchen-Urlaub. Da muss ich die ganzen Tauch-Challenges machen. Du machst die Tauch-Challenges, dafür mache ich den Metalldetektor am Strand, glaube ich. Das passt mir eher, das ist eher meins. Mit so einem riesigen Magneten an einem Seil. Das finde ich immer so die besten Schatzjäger. Gibt es auf YouTube ganz viel. Ich meine, Schatzjäger hat man ja normalerweise irgendwie so Indiana-Jones-Typ vor Augen, irgendwie so Kompass und Hut und so, aber die modernen Schatzjäger haben einfach einen riesigen Magneten an einem Seil. Das ist ihr Werkzeug. Das war es so. Und dann fahren die mit ihrem VW Polo irgendwo an den See und werfen ihren riesigen Magneten an einem Seil in den See. Wie funktionieren Magnete? Man weiß nie, man weiß es. Und zieht ihn raus und dann hängt er halt so ein altes Fahrrad dran. Und du denkst dir, das ist jetzt aus der Romantik des Schatzsuchers geworden? Einfach ein Stück Metall an einem Seil, das ist es? Das ist es. War es aber streng genommen immer schon. Nein, da musst du Karten lesen und dann schauen und dann drei Schritte an dem Baum entlang und dann musst du gucken, dann hast du den Dolch und guckst, wo genau die Ruinen, die Silhouette des Dolchs genau abpassen und dann kommst du da an. Oh, übrigens, ganz kurz, wo wir noch bei Musik sind, jemand hat die Playlist, könnt ihr gerne gucken, die Playlist von Wer wird Millionär verlinkt. Und du hattest recht, es gibt ja tatsächlich eine andere Musik für jede Fragenstufe. Und es gibt auch immer pro Fragenstufe ein anderes richtig oder falsch Geräusch. Das ist ja fantastisch, das ist mir noch nie aufgefallen. Wer wird Millionär sind 80% Sounds. Ja, wirklich. Aber ich höre euch das mal an und seid klug. Also, zurück mal ganz kurz, warum gibt es das nicht? Weil, das meine ich auch mit, warum gibt es nicht eine Harry-Potter-Tour oder mal so eine Transsilvanien-Urlaub oder sowas, wo man einfach mal drei Tage lang komplett in so eine Rolle schlüpfen darf und genau so behandelt wird. Oder so ein Urlaub auf so einer Burg. In Deutschland gibt es wahnsinnig tolle Burgen. Warum kann man da nicht mal irgendwie so ein Mittelalterwochenende machen, wo du vorher eine Rolle bekommst und dann bist du die für ein ganzes Wochenende lang. Und weil, wenn es sowas gibt, ist es immer, ja, eigentlich ist man immer zu alt, dann hat man noch Kinder in der Gruppe und dann werden, und dann hat einer ein Handy noch an und dann geht das Handy los. Naja, da brauchst du so Re-Enactment-Larb-Gruppen eigentlich, die sowas machen. Und dann gehen so, kommen so Kinder und dann, jetzt gehen wir alle nochmal zur Toilette und dann muss man so Rätsel lösen, aber dann werden die Rätsel auch irgendwie verraten, weil es mir auch um das, es ist wie so, ich will ja so ein fullblown Experience haben. Aber ich glaube, sowas gibt es schon auch. Also ich glaube, ich weiß nicht, ob das so von so Urlaubssachen angeboten wird, aber da gibt es schon so Gruppen, die dann irgendwie dann auch so historische Sachen nachspielen
irgendwie dann und so
dann wirklich als Soldaten dann so drei Tage
dann irgendwo hin marschieren und dann das machen und so.
Und das gibt es bestimmt, es gibt auch
so Zauberer, Harry Potter Schule und so,
in Polen gibt es da irgendwas, so ein Fake Hogwarts.
Ja. Aber es ist natürlich
auf Kinder ausgerichtet, weil es
ist ja schon was anderes. Ne, ohne den Kinderscheiß. Ja, ich verstehe schon, du willst keine Kinder. So, und diese Nummer müsst ihr anrufen, wenn ihr nach Hause wollt. Diese ganzen Scheiss und zum Mittag müsst ihr kurz ankreuzen unten, auch wenn dein Pergament kannst du ankreuzen, ob du vegan bist oder nicht. Nein, diesen ganzen Bullshit will ich nicht haben. Ich will einfach nur, ich will die Sicherheitseinweisung nicht, diesen Aspekt nicht. Diesen Wert, welche Allergien, im Mittelalter war es allen egal. Ich will nicht ein Motorboot mit einem Segel, wo wir alle so tun, als würden wir segeln, nein, es ist ein Motorboot, wir können den Motor hören, wir hören ihn. Wir hören ihn, ich höre ihn jetzt gerade. Wir hören das Funkgerät, wir hören die Hafenwache. Wenn ich in einer großen Halle sitze und da hinten ein Feuerlöscher, rast sich aus. Da hinten ist ein Feuerlöscher, ich sehe einen Feuerlöscher, es gab keinen Feuerlöscher, bei Harry Potter hatten die keinen Feuerlöscher. Wir können auch nicht zaubern, ja fuck you! Vielleicht müssen wir sowas organisieren, vielleicht können wir das organisieren, die Leute wissen gar nicht. Hochgradig illegal, weil es gegen sämtliche Vorkehrungen ... Ja. Aber ich, genau, weil das ist so eine fullblown ... Ja, ich glaub, du darfst das halt nicht in Deutschland machen. So, das klingt jetzt blöd, aber ich glaub, du musst halt Polen hinfahren. Ich weiß nicht, warum Polen, aber da gibt es glaube ich auch so gerade so was Kriegsrenagment gibt, auch eine große Fanbase, aber es gibt glaube ich schon Länder, wo die Auflagen nicht so hart sind, wo du auch mal nicht unbedingt den Feuerlöscher auf deinem Schiff brauchst. Und irgendwie Sonnencreme verpflichtend ist oder so. Ja, genau. Obwohl, das ist mir passiert. Ich war ja auf einem Lab, auf einem Das Schwarze Auge Lab in so einer Mittelalter Fantasy-Welt. Und wir waren halt den ganzen Tag draußen und ich hatte halt keine Sonnencreme dabei, weil ich habe mich halt wie so ein mittelalterlicher Mensch vorbereitet. Ich liebe es. Und ich hatte einen gnadenlosen Sonnenbrand und ich war der Sonne völlig ausgeliefert und ich war wirklicherstört. Aber waren damals Ritter knackebraun oder auch einfach Sonnenbrand all the way? Ja, das ist die Frage. Ich glaube schon, dass die ein bisschen mehr abgehärtet waren, aber hast ja auch einen Helm auf und halt so einen Sonnenschirm oder so. Und du nicht? Nee, ich nicht. Man merkt, dass ja erst zu spät. Man merkt, ja, sowas in der Richtung. Man merkt das ja erst viel zu spät, dass man Sonnenbrandbrand hat und sich darum kümmern muss. Und du bist ja in dieser Mittelalterwelt und denkst dir, oh, okay, krass, das Turnier und oh, der edle Rittersmann und jetzt gibt's gleich Brot. Jetzt gibt's gleich Brot? Wahrscheinlich aber wirklich ein sehr beliebtes Gefühl damals auch im Mittelalter. Ah, lecker Brot. Lecker Brot, ja.
War das auch gar nicht lecker, oder? Ich weiss nicht, ob Leute damals überhaupt ein Konzept von, das schmeckt
jetzt gut. Ja, genau, außer macht mich satt.
Ob es irgendwas gab, hinüber,
es macht mich jetzt einfach nur satt. Also so
ab und zu schon bestimmt, wenn man mal Fleisch
gegessen hat oder so. Man weiss auch nicht, ob das Fleisch damals gut
geschmeckt hat im Sinne von, wurde
das gewürzt, Pfeffer gab es nicht, Salz
wahrscheinlich hatte auch nicht jeder. Ist das dann noch so lecker? Ich habe keine Ahnung, weiß ich nicht. So schöne Volkskohle? Aber das hätte ich ganz gerne. Vielleicht können wir das auch mal organisieren. Aber du willst schön Royal Navy, Flugdecker Karibik. Ich will ohne Motor ein Holzschiff, was mit Wind segelt. Ich will eine Schatzsuche, ich will auf einer Einzelneninsel ausgesetzt werden. Und wenn ich dann nicht selber runterkomme, dann scheiss drauf, da habe ich es auch nicht verdient. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob es heutzutage überhaupt noch Leute gibt, die so ein Schiff überhaupt fahren können. Also es gibt ja so die Gorch Fock und sowas, so Segelschiffe. Die Passat in Travemünde. Aber wenn du dann einfach so random, ob das so trivial ist, so ein Schiff zu fahren, das müsste man dann lernen. Das ist so geil. Ich meine, ich hätte auch so Bock. Ich denke mir wirklich immer, wenn ich so eine lange Zugfahrt habe oder so, denke ich mir, was würde ich machen, wenn ich auf einer Insel ausgesetzt bin mit so ein paar Leuten. Welche Rolle habe ich? Was ist meine Aufgabe? Was kann ich leisten? Worum kann ich mich kümmern, was die anderen vielleicht nicht können? Und ich komme immer am selben Ergebnis raus, mein Job wäre Trinkwasser. Ich baue eine grosse Anlage, um Salzwasser zu destillieren und in Trinkwasser umzuwandeln. Das heisst, ich habe dann so eine ganz grosse Fläche, wo ich ganz viel Salzwasser dann habe, und es verdunstet dann in der Sonne, und dann fange ich das auf über so Plastikfolien oder so Blätter, na gut, ungünstig, weil es Schatten wirft, und dann sammle ich das. Und dann muss man das aber, dann darf man nicht direkt trinken, sondern muss dann da noch so ein bisschen Dreck und Salz reintun. Und man darf kein destilliertes Wasser trinken, dann wird man krank. Das ist immer meine Aufgabe. Und dann denke ich mir, wenn ich die Wasserversorgung in der Hand habe, dann kontrolliere ich ja alles. Ja, auf eine Art wieder deine Kontrollsucht, die da rauskommt. Ja, auf jeden Fall. Ich will natürlich schon handeln können. Sonst sagst du, ich fiel Kokosnüsse gegen eine Flasche Wasser.
Und am Ende trinken alle Kokosmilch den ganzen Tag und ich bleibe auf meinem widerlichen Krabbenwasser hängen.
Und natürlich fällt da mal ein Krebs rein. Ja, klar.
Schmüttert scheiße.
Ja, aber sind wir auf einer einsamen Insel oder hier schön in einem Sternenressort?
In einem Rewe. Nein, wir sind hier auf der, wir können uns nicht auf Namen einigen Insel, leider. Nee, ich würde so, ich würde die Aufgaben verteilen. Ich wäre so ein Verteiler. Ja, ich glaube, es ist auch der der Chef, der als erstes eine Anweisung gibt. Ja. Es ist nicht, wer ist der Kompetent, sondern der erste, der sagt so, so, jetzt setzt euch
mal alle mal hier hin.
Ja, ich habe drei Folgen Bear Grylls geguckt, ich bin jetzt hier der Chef.
Ja, und jeder akzeptiert sofort dich als Anführer, wenn du nur einmal eine Ansage machst und
dann heißt es, naja.
Ist ja auch okay, es muss ja erstmal jemanden geben und dann gibt es halt die Kämpfe,
Machtkämpfe, da kann man mich ja auch ankämpfen, herausfordern zum Duell.
Du würdest sofort einknicken, ne? Nö. Ne, ich würde sofort einknicken, wenn jemand sagt, ich will Chef sein, okay. Ich muss noch ganz kurz unsere Verantwortung als, ja, neu gekürte Namenskompetenz Rechnung tragen. Ja, die Seite ist online, namesnamesnamesnames.com ist online, aber da wir noch keine Namen haben,
ist da noch nichts. Das heißt, falls ihr Ideen für coole Namen für Bands, Restaurants, Filme habt, schreibt an names at names names names names.com und wir haben auf jeden Fall einen Hilferuf bekommen. Und Stefan, wir sind gute Leute, oder? Ja. So, wir haben einen Hilferuf bekommen, Und zwar geht es um einen Namen, und zwar in grosser Not ist Bernhard. Und zwar hat Bernhard, wohnt in Pfaffenhofen und dort gibt es ein Hallenbad. Und dieses Hallenbad ist schön, da kann man baden, planschen, rutschen, ja, alles, sich umziehen, und den an diesen komischen, weirden Space-Föhns, alles dran. Alles dran. Aber das Hallenbad hat keinen Namen. Es hat keinen Namen. Du willst mir sagen, dass Bernhard und seinem Hallenbad aus Paffenhofen keinen vernünftigen Namen für sein Hallenbad hat? Ich weiss nicht, ob es sein Hallenbad ist, ehrlich gesagt. Ich glaube nur, dass er auf dieses Problem hinweisen möchte. Und es gibt tatsächlich eine Website mittlerweile, die eingerichtet wurde, für eine Namensfindung für dieses Hallenbad. Und zwar ist das pfaffenhofen.de slash Artikel slash Hallenbad. Ich möchte es Namen Calypso ins Rennen bringen oder Theia Dalma. Ihr könnt sowohl wir als auch jeder andere kann auf dieser Webseite einen Namensvorschlag machen. Natürlich der Hinweis bitte trollt da nicht, macht keinen Scheiss, so ist nicht lustig. Aber falls ihr wirklich coole Ideen habt, ich meine natürlich sag ich mal irgendwas, was mit Podcast-Ufo zutun hat, wäre natürlich ein kleiner Stern am Himmel dieses Podcasts, wenn ein Hallenbart in Pfaffenhofen ... Das Podcast-Ufo-Bart? Nee. Nee, das Bart-Ufo, na ja, so ganz einfach ist das doch nicht. Aber falls uns was einfällt oder falls euch was einfällt, unterstützt bitte auf jeden Fall Bernhard, wir als Namens-Podcast, als Namensgeber-Podcast, glaube ich, können da auf jeden Fall nachhelfen. Ja, als kreativste Community Deutschlands. Aber Charypso finde ich schon ganz cool, so ein Abgrund, so Nebukadnezar oder so. Mama, können wir noch ins Nebukadnezar? Finde ich richtig gut. Aber ich meine Hallenbad. Chalypsobad Pfaffenhofen. Einfach, wir können ja auch eine Kategorie für Bäder machen auf Names, Names, Names. Auf jeden Fall, können wir auf jeden Fall auch mit aufnehmen. Schreibt eure Ideen entweder direkt auf die Webseite pfaffenhofen.de slash artikel slash hallenbad. Und wir helfen Bernhard natürlich auf als Community, wir sind ein Schwarmorganismus, wir kommen da ran und wir freuen uns sehr, was da tatsächlich dann draus wird aus diesem Hallenbad. Tümpel. Tolle Aktion, auf jeden Fall, wir helfen gerne, falls ihr
Namen braucht, wir helfen natürlich immer gerne. Genau.
Super gut, finde ich gut, bin gespannt, in welche Richtung
das geht. Wir überlegen uns was, wir schicken
auf jeden Fall auch was ein, auf jeden Fall schicken wir uns ein.
Und gucken dann mal, wer tatsächlich gewinnen wird,
ob ihr dabei seid oder nicht, natürlich als
kleiner Preis obendrauf winkt.
Eine
Reise
nach Port Royal, Kingston, ins Port Royal Paffenhofen, das ist ein kleines Restaurant, ins Cortez Paffenhofen. Ich fände immer mal geil, wenn man ein Gewinnspiel macht, wo man nur die Hinreise geschenkt bekommt.
Ja, genau.
Das ist ein Hawaii, aber nur der Hinflug für eine Person. Weil man den günstig geschossen hat. Ohne Gepäck, ohne Handgepäck. Das ist mal verlosen irgendwann. Wenn man so günstig angeboten bekommt, nur die Hinreise, ohne Handgepäck. Aber so richtig weit, so richtig Abu Dhabi. Ja, Hawaii, eher Neuseeland oder sowas. Ja, genau. Hinflug nach Neuseeland und dann guck mal, was du machst, du Depp. Ja, guck mal, ciao, ciao, ciao. Herzlichen Glückwunsch. Auf eine Art ein geiler Preis. Ein toller Preis, toller Preis. Apropos Preis in, wir machen nächste Woche noch eine Folge und dann machen wir eine kleine Sommerpause und wir haben eine kleine Ankündigung, oder? Wir haben eine Ankündigung, völlig richtig, denn wir, gemeint, Flo und Himmel und Schermatize, gehen wieder auf Tour! Jetzt wundert ihr euch wahrscheinlich und sagt, Moment mal, da läuft doch gerade noch eine Tour. Die haben doch zwei Termine, nämlich Berlin und Köln, nochmal verschoben. Es ist doch gerade schon eine Tour und wir sagen, ja, stimmt, aber wir kriegen nicht genug. Wir wollen noch weitere Shows spielen, auf jeden Fall. Wir wollen noch weitere Live-Podcasts machen, deswegen kündigen wir hier offiziell an unsere vierte Tour.
Die grossartige Tour 2021 und zwar sind wir, es beginnt direkt im Januar 2021 in Leipzig, am 13. Januar sind wir in Leipzig im Haus Auensee, am 16.2. sind wir in Bochum im Starlight Express Theater, am 31.3. sind wir in Hamburg in der Leisthalle, am 2.5. in Berlin im Bodekalsaal, am 17.6. sind wir in Wien, am 30.10. sind wir in München und am 30.11. sind wir in Hannover. Ja, dann machen wir uns einen schönen Tag in München. In München sind wir im Z Krone, da freue ich mich auch wahnsinnig drauf. Also die ganzen Locations, es ist ein bisschen größer, wird eine lustige Tour, glaube ich. Das ganze 2021 bereisen wir also Deutschland und Österreich. Wir hoffen dann, dass wir bis dahin natürlich auch normal auftreten können, so wie wir es gewohnt sind, wie damals. Und natürlich alle Informationen findet ihr wie immer natürlich auch bei uns auf Twitter und Facebook. Genau, und die Nachhol finden trotzdem auch genauso statt in halt der neuen neuen tour kosmos genau das vermischt sich so ein bisschen das ist ein bisschen merkwürdig aber wir müssen gucken dass wir einfach das richtige program am richtigen abend spielen ja wir machen noch mal ein Diagramm ihr werdet das verstehen und wir freuen uns auf euch euch zu sehen der Vorverkauf ist am Mittwoch richtig völlig richtig lieber Stefan hier ist Florentin aus der Zukunft und bestätigt Vorverkauf ist am Mittwoch, richtig? Völlig richtig, lieber Stefan,
hier ist Florentin aus der Zukunft und bestätigt,
Vorverkauf startet am 8.7.
um 11 Uhr.
Wir freuen uns sehr.
Kauft gerne Tickets, wir würden uns sehr freuen, wenn wir euch auf der Tour sehen.
Wir freuen uns auf euch, macht's gut
und habt noch eine schöne Woche, wir sehen uns bis
nächste Woche und wir heben ab.